If you've got a Bible with you, please turn with me to Romans chapter 15.
It's also there in your worship guide if you need that.
In Romans chapter 15 verse 6, we're told that the church has been brought together that
we might glorify God with one voice.
And over the past couple of weeks, we've been looking at this kind of short series,
just looking at Romans 15 and seeing what it means for us to come together to glorify
God with one voice.
You saw, first of all, we glorify Him with our worship.
That includes singing praises to God as we've just done, but it's so much more than that
as well.
It's ultimately humbling our lives, ourselves before the Lord that He might be exalted.
Everything we do should be out of a heart of worship to the Lord because of His great
glory, His worthiness.
But also, we are to glorify God through our welcome.
So we're to welcome one another within the life of the church as we have been welcomed
by Jesus.
And as we welcome one another, we begin to grow together in the likeness of Christ.
And then lastly, which is where we're at today, we see that we are going to glorify
God through our witness.
That's what we're called to as well.
So we don't just want to glorify God behind closed doors in the life of the church.
We want His glory to shine out from here throughout North Jefferson and the communities
we're part of and on to the ends of the earth.
So Romans chapter 15, this morning we're going to read verses 14 down to the end of the chapter.
It says, I myself am satisfied about you, my brothers, that you yourselves are full of
goodness filled with all knowledge and able to instruct one another.
But on some points I have written to you very boldly by way of reminder because of
the grace given to me by God.
To be a minister of Christ Jesus to the Gentiles in the priestly service of the Gospel of God.
So that the offering of the Gentiles may be acceptable, sanctified by the Holy Spirit.
In Christ Jesus then I have reason to be proud of my work for God.
For I will not venture to speak of anything except what Christ has accomplished through
me to bring the Gentiles to obedience by word and deed.
By the power of signs and wonders.
By the power of the Spirit of God.
So that from Jerusalem and all the way around to Illyricum I have fulfilled the ministry
of the Gospel of Christ.
And thus I make it my ambition to preach the Gospel not where Christ has already been
named lest I build on someone else's foundation.
But as it is written, those who have never been told of Him will see and those who
have never heard will understand.
This is the reason why I have so often been hindered from coming to you.
But now since I no longer have any room to work in these regions and since I have longed
for many years to come to you, I hope to see you in passing as I go to Spain and be helped
on my journey there by you.
Once I have enjoyed your company for a while.
At present however I am going to Jerusalem bringing aid to the saints.
For Macedonia and Achaia have been pleased to make some contribution for the poor among
the saints at Jerusalem.
For they were pleased to do it and indeed they owe it to them for if the Gentiles have
come to share in their spiritual blessings they ought also to be of service to them in
material blessings.
When therefore I have completed this and have delivered to them what has been collected,
I will leave for Spain by way of you.
I know that when I come to you I will come in the fullness of the blessing of
Christ.
I appeal to you brothers by our Lord Jesus Christ and by the love of the Spirit to strive
together with me in your prayers to God on my behalf that I may be delivered from the
unbelievers in Judea.
That my service for Jerusalem may be acceptable to the saints so that by God's will I
may come to you with joy and be refreshed in your company.
May the God of peace be with you all.
Amen.
This is the word of the Lord.
Let's pray.
Lord as we come now to your word I pray that you would open our eyes that we might be
hold wondrous things there.
I pray that your spirit would open the eyes of our hearts that we might be hold more
of the glory of Jesus.
Lord I pray that we would be drawn to him and that we would be changed into his
likeness.
We pray this in his name.
Amen.
Well during a visit to the NASA Space Center back in 1962 President John F. Kennedy
noticed a janitor who was there.
He was pushing his broom and he interrupted the tour and kind of walked over to the man
and said he introduced himself.
He said, hi I'm Jack Kennedy.
What are you doing there?
And the janitor replied, well Mr. President I'm helping to put a man on the moon.
So this man had a specific job.
He was the janitor but he saw what he was doing in light of the greater
mission that he was part of.
So we all have different areas of service in the life of the church that we are
called to and yet we have a greater mission that we are all part of.
We are all called to make God's glory known yes here but also to the ends of
the earth.
You see this here in Romans 15 up to this point we have seen that it's
always been God's plan to bring about his praise from all peoples by showing
the mercy in Christ.
It was his plan from the beginning to bring people from all nations to himself,
to bring about his praise that we might with one voice glorify God as we've been
seeing.
And if you're in Christ you are part of that global body called the church.
But now Paul is shifting in Romans 15 from speaking about us as being recipients
of the mercy of God to us also being participants in the mission of God.
So yes we are among those nations that have been shown mercy in Christ but also
participants in the mission of God to make that gospel, the gospel of Jesus known
throughout the world.
And so that's what we're going to be seeing this morning.
We've been saved by the gospel, yes we've also been sent out to proclaim
that gospel to the world in our witness.
So as we go through this section we're not going to look at everything
unfortunately although I'm very tempted to do that.
We'll hopefully see enough here that we might do two things.
One is we need to understand this mission that we've been given and two we need to
engage in it, be involved in it, get plugged in.
Alright so this is what Paul is.
He's writing to this church.
He clearly wants them to understand the mission work that he's involved in
but he also wants them to see the part they have to play in it and the same
thing applies to us.
So first of all understand the mission.
Alright so what Paul is or the people that Paul is writing to here isn't just
like a group of pastors or a group of missionaries that they might
understand the mission.
He's writing to every believer, every member of the church.
You see God wants you to know what his word teaches about global mission.
If you've got your Bible with you and you can look at that previous
section that we were reading over the past couple of weeks where you have
all these promises from the Old Testament laid before us showing us
that it was God's plan all along to bring the nations to himself.
Although he made himself known to Israel it was his plan to make himself
known through them to the world as well.
And as we move forward in this chapter we want us to see that Paul wants us
to continue to understand a bit more about mission.
So he wants us to understand the kind of the biblical backdrop to it
which we've already seen.
But there's say three more things that we need to understand.
One, we need to understand that this work of mission is a priestly work.
You see that in verses 14 to 16 in what we read.
See the Old Testament doesn't just give us promises about God's plan for the world.
It also gives us pictures that point us to what God has planned for the world as well.
And Paul gives us one of them here in verse 16.
He talks about his calling to be a minister of Christ Jesus to the Gentiles
or to the nations of the world in the priestly service of the gospel of God.
So he sees this work as priestly work.
What does he mean by that?
He's not talking about like, you know, he's wearing a black suit and a white collar
or any other kind of modern ideas of what we might have about the priesthood.
But neither is he suiting up like a priest in the Old Testament offering sacrifices
in the same exact way that they were offering sacrifices.
He's not doing that either.
So what is he talking about here then when he talks about his work as being a priestly work?
Well, he is referring back to the priesthood in the Old Testament,
but he is saying that the work that they did illustrates and really points to the mission work
that he is now involved in.
All right, so it's a kind of, it's a picture of mission.
So the Old Testament priests, what were they doing?
They were standing as God's representatives on earth before man
and standing as a representative of man before God.
And when they came before God, they came bringing sacrifices,
offering these sacrifices in worship as they had been directed by God.
What does that have to do with mission?
What does that have to do with Paul's work of preaching the gospel among the nations?
Well, it doesn't mean that we need a, you know, that he's serving as a kind of mediator
between God and man.
So we no longer need a priest to represent us before God
or somebody to offer sacrifices on our behalf for our sins
because that has already been done in Jesus.
You see, Jesus is our great high priest who stands as our perfect representative before God.
He's offered his life upon the cross as a once and for all sacrifice,
not to just cover our sins temporarily, but to put them away forever.
So this sacrifice has already been offered and he stands before God on our behalf.
And so if you are in Christ, you are before the Father,
perfectly cleansed from your sin through what Jesus has done.
So Paul writes in 1 Timothy 2.5,
so there is one mediator between God and man, the man Christ Jesus.
So what is he saying?
He's saying that his work, this is Paul, is like the work of a priest.
So I hope we have this image in view now.
So when Paul stands before others, here's how it's like being a priest.
He's standing consciously as a representative of God.
He knows that he's representing the Lord in the places that he goes and the people he speaks to.
So in that sense, he is standing between God and man as someone who's representing the Lord.
And his work is an act of worship.
What is he aiming to bring?
He's aiming to bring the nations to God as a kind of offering.
He preaches the gospel so that,
he's a priestly service in the gospel of God,
so that, this is verse 16 again,
the offering of the Gentiles may be acceptable sanctified by the Holy Spirit.
So he knows that it's only through Christ that people are accepted before God.
So what does he do?
He preaches the gospel of Christ about his death and his resurrection
so that he might bring the Gentiles before the Lord.
As the people who are now cleansed, welcome by God in Christ.
All right, so what does this speak to us about then in terms of our priestly work?
So Paul is representing the Lord, preaching the gospel,
that he might bring the Gentiles, the nations of the world as an acceptable offering
in Christ before the Lord.
Well, what does that mean for us?
Well, in the Old Testament, it's interesting.
Yes, there were people who were uniquely called to this role of being a priest,
but also that language of the priesthood was used to speak of God's people as a whole.
So the whole nation of Israel were a kind of priest before the nations.
So you look at Exodus chapter 19, verses four to six.
Israel, God says, has been given this priestly role before the nations
to be a kingdom of priests.
So they were to represent the Lord before the nations of the world.
And similarly, the church today has a priestly calling to live out.
We live as God's representatives in the world and we proclaim the gospel
so that the nations might be brought to God in worship.
I'm not just kind of making that inference up.
You look at what the apostle Peter had to write in one or first Peter chapter two in verse nine.
He says, but you are a chosen race, a royal priesthood, a holy nation,
a people for his own possession that you may proclaim the excellencies of him
who called you out of darkness into his marvelous light.
So it's great that you got people like Paul who were going out to represent the Lord
in the kind of far flung places around the world.
People have never heard, but this is something we're all called to.
So us right here, wherever you live, you're called to represent the Lord.
If you know him, you're to represent him that we might be part of God bringing others to himself.
So how does this work out in your context?
You know, I hope that all of us here are meaningfully engaging with people who don't know the Lord.
You know, it can be easy to just to just find kind of Christian friends
who are on the same page with you and spend all your time there
without actually taking the time to come alongside other people
so that they too can come to know him as well, whether that's a common hobby
or whatever it is for you to come alongside others.
Let's all make sure that we are in places where we can represent the Lord well there.
And if we're there, are we actually speaking of him or are we staying silent?
So it's priestly work.
We also need to understand that it's a powerful work.
You see that in verses 17 to 19.
So Paul is describing here what he's seeing as he's going from city to city.
He's seeing some amazing things.
You can see the stories being told in the book of Acts.
So he's going to places who have never heard of Jesus and he's preaching
and he's seeing people come to faith, turning from their old ways, embracing Christ.
They're coming together, being gathered together into the life of the church.
They're now growing as disciples and he's seeing this all over the place.
You know, if this was in modern times, we we might get the apostle Paul and say,
like, hey, like what's your secret?
You can imagine him maybe being like offered like book deals
or being asked to come speak at conferences or like, you know,
a webinar or something like what's what's your secret, Paul?
How have you done this?
Now can we replicate that here?
Well, here's Paul's answer.
Here's how it happened.
You ready?
Let's go to verse 17.
He speaks of his work for God, but then you go to verse 18.
He says, but I will not venture to speak of anything except what Christ
has accomplished through me.
So here's how he did it.
Christ accomplished his work through Paul by the power of the Spirit.
It wasn't Paul's winsomeness.
It wasn't his his methods.
It wasn't his charisma.
It was the power of Christ.
And Paul's not kind of, you know, putting forward like a kind of false humility here.
This is the truth.
The power that brought people to faith in Christ was inherit in the message itself.
It was the Spirit of God opening people's eyes to see who Jesus truly is.
And what he has done for them.
In recent years, there was a fairly high profile journalist called Molly Worthing,
who came to faith in Christ.
And and there's been different interviews with her.
And it's been amazing here about her kind of like faith journey.
But I also heard an interview with a man who was influential in her coming to faith.
He was somebody who used to meet with her and kind of answer her questions.
And by the way, she wasn't just a journalist.
She was somebody who kind of studied evangelicalism and kind of wrote about the
church in America and not in a positive light at all.
And so as part of her research, she's got to get around Christians and ask her
questions and that kind of thing.
And so one of the pastors was spending time answering her questions.
And the Lord used him to to point her to Jesus and she ended up coming to
faith herself. But people asked him, so what?
So, so how did that happen?
And he said this, he used an illustration, which I think would kind of go down
well in Alabama.
He says it was kind of like pulling the trigger on a rifle, on a high power rifle.
He says, the moment you pull the trigger back, you realize that there's far more
power coming from the gun than the power you're putting into the gun.
He said, it wouldn't, it wouldn't matter if it was somebody who was
small or big or whatever.
The power isn't in the person who is holding it.
The power is in the instrument itself when it goes off.
He says, it was like that.
He's like, I don't feel like I did anything special at all.
Anybody could have done what I was doing because the power wasn't in me.
The power was in the gospel.
The power was the power of God.
It was the power of the spirit.
And so this is a wonderful thing for me to know.
And I hope for you as well, that whether or not you feel able to share
your faith with others in a convincing way or whatever, that the power is not
in you. It's not in me.
We could simply share the message and God works powerfully.
All right.
This is what the spirit uses to do this powerful work.
He uses word and deeds to see that at verse 18.
So Christ has accomplished this through me to bring the gentiles to
obedience by word and deed.
So like, how does Christ work powerfully through us?
By word and deed, by, you might say proclamation and demonstration.
So proclamation.
So Paul knows he's got to actually share the message if it's going to be
effective in people's lives.
If their lives are going to be changed by it.
So he doesn't use the excuse of saying, well, some people share the gospel
through their words, but I'm just going to do it through my life.
People don't actually need to hear.
They'll just they'll just see me and kind of like infer the kind of
hint and hope method of evangelism.
And I know that I know that can be said sometimes.
And I know we mean well when we say that.
But at the end of the day, remember the gospel is news.
It is a message.
The name of Jesus must be spoken, right?
It must be declared.
Now, while we may be timid, the one thing that will help us to give over
our get over our timidity in this is just remembering just how glorious
the gospel is and how God works powerfully through it.
And this is what Paul said back in Romans one, 16.
He says, I am not ashamed of the gospel.
Why?
For it is the power of God unto salvation.
To all who believe.
He says, I'm not ashamed of it because I know it's powerful.
I've seen it work.
I've seen the change it brings into people's lives.
And so he preached that gospel has to be shared.
But that sharing needs to be alongside demonstration as well.
Word indeed must come together.
So deeds point to the truthfulness of the gospel.
And Paul mentioned specifically here signs and wonders there in in verse
19 by the power of signs and wonders, by the power of the spirit of God.
And Paul's preaching was often accompanied by miracles.
And we could do a kind of deep dive study in this.
But you see in like Second Corinthians, Chapter two, that these miracles
like showed that he was truly an apostle that kind of authenticated his
apostleship. They also demonstrated that the gospel was for the Gentiles
as well as for the Jews.
You see that in places like Acts, Chapter 15.
It was like the spirit of God's stamp of approval to say that the gospel is not
just for Jews, it's for Gentiles as well.
These signs and wonders that were happening.
But the purpose of the signs and wonders that were happening were ultimately
to point to the truthfulness of the message that was being proclaimed.
So what God did through these signs and wonders ultimately was
was done in order to bring about, what does it say?
In verse 18, there in the middle, to bring the Gentiles to obedience.
So the aim was so that people might come to know the Lord.
Now, the power of the spirit can be made visible by miraculous signs and wonders.
Absolutely. And I still believe that that can be the case today, too.
However, but the primary way that this is seen is not in perpetual miracles,
rather the power of the spirit is seen in the lives that are being
transformed by the power of the gospel.
Right. That is the aim.
And that change in our walk is integral to our witness.
So as our lives are changed by the power of the gospel
and our lives reflect Jesus, we can speak about Jesus knowing that others can
see what he is like and what it's like to be reconciled to God through him
by the change that's taken place in our lives.
So 1 Peter chapter two in verse 12 says, keep your conduct
among the Gentiles honorable so that when they speak against you as
evildoers, they may see your good deeds and glorify God on the day of visitation.
So we don't choose between our our words or our works when it comes to making
Christ known. God works powerfully when both of those are brought together
when we make Christ known in word and deed.
So what's the result here?
Of Paul doing this.
Well, his ministry, it's verse 19.
Paul can say that from Jerusalem all the way around to Illyricum.
That's modern day Albania, by the way.
He says, I have fulfilled the ministry of the gospel of Christ.
He even goes so far as to say in verse 23.
So there's no more room for me to work in these regions.
So hang on.
Just think about this.
Imagine being one of these one of these believers reading this for the
first time or hearing it in Paul says, there's no more room for me to
work in these regions.
They might be thinking, well, hang on a second, Paul.
This is the first time this message has ever gone to any of these regions.
There's still thousands of people in the area you described, like from
Jerusalem all the way up to southern Albania.
I have nothing else to do in these areas.
What are you talking about, Paul?
All these people are still lost.
What do you mean?
You don't have anything else to do.
I can think of plenty for you to do there.
So it wasn't that there was any, it wasn't that there was no work left to
do. It was that his work was finished there.
There was no more work for him to do because the church had been planted
there and that was over to them to be a witness in the community that
they had been planted in.
So that's how he could say, I no longer have work to do in these areas
because he planted the church and now they had the responsibility of
that work locally.
So another thing we need to understand is that it's it's a
pioneering work as well, a pioneering work that he's called
to here in mission.
So verse 20, love this verse.
So Paul says, and thus I make it my ambition now that I've planted
these churches in these other places to preach the gospel, not where
Christ has already been named, lest I build on someone else's foundation.
So Paul continued to care about these churches like he cares enough
about this church in Rome, which he didn't plant, but he cares
about churches enough to write a letter like this to them.
He's actually, we're not going to have time to get into this,
but in what we read, we see that he's he's taking up a
collection for churches in need to help to alleviate poverty
in those churches.
So he cares for churches, but his primary ambition was to preach
the gospel where Christ hadn't been named to see new churches
planted in those areas that were previously unreached.
He uses the kind of building work as an example of what he's
talking about.
So he kind of lays the foundation, but then the kind of
ongoing maintenance of the building, so to speak, is over to
other people.
Like he lays the foundation and other people kind of continue
the building work and keep it up.
You know, so most people to just bring this to modern day,
what will stay in a local church and they'll make their home
there and they'll serve there.
And that's great.
But there are others who have the same God given ambition
that the Apostle Paul describes for himself here.
They just can't shake the fact that there are places in the
world where people have never heard the name of Jesus,
where people don't know him, where there aren't churches.
They had this drive to go to those places where gospel
foundations have not yet been laid.
Now that might be hard for us to even think in a place like
Alabama, you know, some 2000 years later, like there's
still places in the world like this.
What do you mean no churches?
Like you drive down the road.
I mean, you can just count church after church after
church where we are.
And 2000 years later, can there really be places where
the gospel still hasn't gone?
And the answer is there sure are.
I was talking with Sam earlier about I went to go visit
some missionary friends in Central Asia and the country
there.
And I remember visiting them and they they had this kind
of outdoor ministry where they would go into this kind of
mountainous region.
It's a Muslim majority country.
And though these really remote people groups where
they're cut off for a good chunk of the year because
of snow, like ski is the only way you can get to
them.
And he was there and he had a map on his wall
because he had been out to some of those remote regions
and he was he put a dot and another dot and another
dot on this map.
And I was talking to him, you know, facing him from
behind.
And so what are all those dots you're putting up
there?
And so those those are all those are all villages
that I visited.
And that was in a region where there were no
believers.
There were no churches.
There were no missionaries.
And it was hard to reach.
So it wasn't just that there were people there who
were lost.
There are thousands of people there who were lost
and nobody there to tell them.
No church to visit to find out more.
Nobody who spoke their language who could speak
the message of Jesus to them.
And he was working in another people group working
on that language.
It was just going out to see like what would it
take to access some of these remote peoples?
You know, there are over over three billion
people in the world today who are living in a
people group or a place just like that
where they don't have a local church that is
that is proclaiming the gospel to that local
area.
So there are places just like what Paul is
describing here where the foundation still
needs to be laid.
And so Christ will be worshiped by people from
every nation.
So Paul is confident of this.
He brings one more verse in verse 21
according from Isaiah.
Those who have never been told of him will
see and those who have never heard will
understand.
So he's got that, you know, that's that's
throbbing inside of him.
He knows that Christ is going to be
worshiped by people from every nation.
But he knows in order for that to happen,
people must proclaim the message there.
And he says, I will go.
And the Lord is still calling people
to go today.
So let's ask that question.
OK, we kind of understand what it's about
the mission.
How can we faithfully engage in that?
Well, we could say a lot here about that,
but let's just say that we all have a role to
play.
Some of us are goers and some of us are
senders, but we are all called to be
involved in God's global mission.
I referred a few months ago to William
Kerry.
You know, he was he was faithfully
proclaiming the gospel in India for like
40 years.
And the Lord used him both in planting
churches, but also in development and so
many ways where he was there serving.
And but he said this, he gathered together
a group of friends right before he went.
This image just sticks in my mind.
He says, I will go if you will
hold the rope.
So in other words, he saw what they were
doing back home as being a vital part of
what was going on in India.
Right.
The supporting part was just as vital as
like you can imagine, like somebody going
down into like a mine or a cave or
something.
Like the people holding onto the rope
are just as vital to that as the
person who's actually going down in it.
And that's how it is with mission.
We need people to go.
We need people to support as well.
So Paul knew he could not fulfill his
mission without people partnering him
in a variety of ways.
And so part of Paul's intention in
writing the book of Romans was to
invite this church into partnership with
him when he goes to the next place,
which was Spain.
That was where he was aiming at going.
It seems like he wants this church in
Rome to be a kind of base of operations
to launch out from.
He wants them to hold the rope as he
goes there.
And that kind of partnership is exactly
what's needed today.
You know, I know some of you personally
partner with missionaries serving in
places around the world.
And that that's wonderful and want to
encourage you in that.
But also as a church, we need to be
a church that's faithfully partnering
with others as well.
Like right from the start.
So we've just so you're aware.
We've already taken on two
two mission partners that we're
supporting regularly.
So we've got the Clint's who are
serving in the Middle East.
They were here a few weeks ago and
they've just arrived back in their
country this week.
And then we've also got the
the Taunton's who were involved in
prison ministry at the Correctional
Facilities. Those are two regular
mission partners that we've gotten
behind as a church.
But we want to pray that the Lord
would raise up more people that he
would show us who to partner with
in other places around the world.
So let's be deliberate and
intentional about that prayerful.
But let's let's see how can we be
faithfully engaging with mission
partnerships as the Lord raises up
people for us to partner with as a
church.
All right. So let's let's just look
at some quick things. One.
Take an active interest.
Not to not to just go back to
this again. But this
this last part of the book of
Romans wasn't written to the
missions committee at the church
in Rome.
It was for everybody.
It was for everybody to take an
interest in actively.
It's for the whole church. God's
heart is for the whole world.
So if our heart is in tune with
his heart we will have a heart
for the world as well.
There's no room for what we'll
get things figured out here first
and then we'll think about what
he's doing in other places.
No God's heart is for the whole
world. And so should ours be
as well.
So on the first I don't know if
you've noticed this I've not really
announced it in this way. But on the
first Sunday of every month we've
prayed for something here at the
front and shared about something we
can be praying for mission wise
and wants to continue that to bring
this before us. This is something for
all of us to be praying about.
I take an interest.
Secondly seek to
encourage.
Paul personally cares for
these believers and he expects
when he goes to spend time with
them he will be refreshed
by them as well.
So seek to be an encouragement
to those you know who are serving
on mission.
Locally and globally.
You know read their newsletters that
they send out and ask somebody
who's lived overseas and sent out
newsletters and heard crickets and
you think did anybody receive it.
How encouraging it is to just have
a quick letter to say thanks so
much for you know for sending
that out praying for you.
You didn't have to be much but
somebody read it.
That's amazing.
You know to seek to be an
encouragement to them in whatever
way you can.
You know when we have folks visit
here come alongside them.
Take an interest in their work.
Thirdly pray for them.
Pray for what they're doing.
Verse 30. Let's go back there.
Paul says I appeal to you.
Brothers by our Lord Jesus Christ
and by the love of the spirit to
strive together with me
in your prayers to God on my
behalf.
Like mission work is hard work.
There's some striving involved.
It can be really discouraging.
Paul says I want you to strive
with me work with me here.
How by praying.
You know your prayers can
can impact in places where you
will never go.
I firmly believe there are people
who have never traveled outside
of this country never traveled
outside of the state.
Whoever an impact globally
through their prayers for what
the Lord is doing in other
places.
So let's pray.
Another thing support the work
of mission. Mark the work
helped in verse 24.
So I hope to be helped on my
journey by you.
That word carries the idea of
caring for travelers
on a journey.
It's used elsewhere in scripture
in the context of like providing
things like material support or
showing hospitality things like
that.
So Paul needs to get to where
he's going and he's going to
need support practical help to
help him to get there.
And the same is true for
missionaries today.
They need practical support,
financial support or
accommodation or a meal when
they're here. Things like that
in order to get to where they
are going to carry on the work
that they're doing.
So let's pray that the Lord will
make us generous
individually and collectively
as a church and giving toward
mission.
One more thing.
So pray and support but also
go now.
This isn't for everybody.
But that word help once again
will sometimes use to talk about
somebody accompanying someone
on a journey by actually going
with them.
I give you references to show
you that that's how the word is
used in the New Testament.
Could it be that one of the ways
Paul is hoping to be helped by
the church is by somebody in
the church saying actually
I'll go with you.
I really want to not just hear
about what's happening in Spain.
I want to go with you to be
involved in that work.
You look in a place like Acts
chapter 20 and verse four.
Paul lists out seven different
people from different places where
he's planted churches who are
now serving alongside him on
his kind of mission team as
he's going in places or going
to places with the gospel.
And they weren't the only ones.
Now some go out for short term
trips sure to support in that way
but others would have gone out
for the long haul.
So let's join together and
praying that the Lord would
make us a church that supports
missionaries by actually going
to where they are to encourage
them. It's been great to have
some folks like the Campbells
or the Nultons going out
to encourage the work of
mission in other places.
But we hope to do that more
short term mission trips but
also we're praying that the
Lord would raise up people from
here to go out long term.
But whatever forms it takes in
the coming months the Lord is
worthy.
He's worthy to be praised by
people from every tribe, tongue
and nation. He wants to use us
as a church to that end as
we join together to glorify
him with one voice from North
Jefferson to the ends of the
earth.